let's talk about the number one worst
food for your heart hint it's not sugar
I did a video on this before but the
problem is the food that I talked about
before um it's not really in the average
person's diet nearly as much as it used
to be and that was trans fats trans fats
are really bad for us but they ban that
so if we take away trans fats what do
you think would be the food that would
be the top of the list as far as
destroying that inside of that artery so
let's see if you can guess and get it
right okay number one it's a primary
driver of heart disease it creates
potent in massive inflammation inside
your arteries and also this food is
directly correlated as far as the
consumption and introduction into our
food supply and the exact statistics of
getting heart disease I mean they're on
the same Trend going up another thing
that this food does very specifically to
the inside of your arteries is it
creates what's called oxidative LDL now
let me just explain what that means now
maybe you've heard that LDL is the bad
cholesterol but really the LDL is not
bad until it gets modified it
changes this particular ingredient that
I'm going to tell you about in a minute
goes into that LDL and it modifies it
and it makes it so it can penetrate
inside the artery wall and start the
Cascade of damage and it's this
repetitive chronic consumption of this
thing that keeps this irritation or
inflammation uh going then you have a
casca of problems like uh incomplete
healing with proteins and cholesterol
till the point where you're developing
this plaque and that can break off Etc
but it really starts with this oxidative
LDL this food also increases the risk of
getting metabolic syndrome what is that
that's a combination of several things
uh low HDL High glycerides high blood
glucose belly fat and also High fasting
insulin and insulin resistance now I
will say there's certain studies that
will show that consuming this food
lowers the cholesterol okay so you might
think oh that's a good thing but at the
same time it increases the risk of
developing heart disease as well as
increasing the risk of dying from heart
disease I'm going to put all that data
down below now it also causes lipid
peroxidation now what does that mean
well think about oxidation is something
going rancid something like rusting
something and damaging it out but also
this substance goes into the membranes
of your cells okay not just the arteries
but other tissues too in the retina it
can go into the brain cells it can
create a lot of problems one of the
secondary uh compounds that's created
I'm not going to get into the long name
but it's called
hn which which is a very very toxic
thing and that can create neuro
degeneration cancer heart disease like
we already mentioned and inflammation
now if we compare 2010 to 2013 there's
been an increase of this by 135 a so
that's a major increase in our bodies
this particular food is made with
similar machines that they make
petroleum products from it's like an
industrial product and it's in our food
chain big time
they heat it at least five times they
run it through this uh very toxic
solvent called hexane to extract it and
isolate it so there's chemicals added
there's bleach added there's other
things to take the odor out so basically
it's void of anything living at all it's
also been known to increase clotting it
creates major oxidative stress which
basically is a is a combination between
High oxidation that rancidity that
rusting out and low antioxidants and by
the way this oxidative LDL there's
really two main ways to lower it one is
it decreases food which I'm just about
to tell you right now but number two is
to decrease smoking that's right smoking
okay so let me reveal what this
is you ready for
this seed oil seed oil now you may have
heard of vegetable oils right like this
right here I if you can see this
vegetable oils they have pictures of
vegetables right here right this does
not come from vegetables right vegetable
oil is really seed oil it's from corn
canola it's from cotton seed they make
it from soy and what's really wild about
this is that this oil is an unsaturated
fatty acid which means means it's very
very unstable it's susceptible to
oxidation which I just mentioned
especially to light air or oxygen
temperature so here we have this product
that's not in a dark bottle and you can
heat it the problem is that this has
already been oxidized because it's been
processed so it's a highly inflammatory
food and we use this in a lot of foods
okay not just in cooking but in salad
dressings in our favorite products like
this in literally all of the ultra
processed foods it's unfortunate now
because if you're cooking at home and
you've been watching any of my videos
you probably are using like either
butter or coconut oil avocado oil or
olive oil right but when you go to a
restaurant they're going to use cheap
oils to cook with now I also looked at
some research that said that uh this
polyunsaturated fatty acid Aid which is
high in omega-6 is not bad for us right
and I found a few studies that talked
about that and I want to kind of just
dissect them because uh the first study
I want to talk about it's called the
finish uh mental hospital study and this
basically supported this theory that
this unsaturated oil is heart healthy
right but there's several flaws in this
study they actually remove the trans fat
and so that leads to the question uh was
it because you removed the trans fats or
you added this we don't know also it
wasn't randomize you had people that
smoked people that didn't you had people
on medications people with high blood
pressure so there's just too many flaws
in that study so just want to take a
little break and tell you thank you so
much for subscribing I really appreciate
all of my subscribers and even those
that don't subscribe but the problem is
even though you might subscribe to my
channel only 1% of all of my subscribers
get notified so I would really
appreciate it's not going to take much
effort to press that Bell if you
subscribe if you haven't subscribed
subscribe and then press that Bell as
well so that way you can continue to get
this uh I think really important
information let's look at another study
Los Angeles Veterans Administration
study so with this one it showed that it
decreased the cholesterol by 133% but no
significant impact on heart attack and
sudden death so for this one it doesn't
say it it improved the heart it said
there was no significant difference but
it wasn't randomized so you have these
groups that some smoked some didn't some
people drank some people didn't so if
someone smoked for example they're going
to eat up their vitamin E and that's
going to put them more at risk for
getting uh heart problems but I'm going
to put a good amount of research Down
Below on more of a randomized control
studies that you could see that give you
um more um proof that this is damaging
so I really think this is an easy
problem to solve it's just an awareness
thing reading labels don't consume these
oils instead of using some type of
typical salad dressing find one that
doesn't have it you're probably just
going to have to use olive oil or some
other type of dressing also the
condiments right you have to find a
condiment that doesn't have the soy oil
it's in mayonnaise it's in a lot of
different sauces and also when you cook
I would use olive oil butter
coconut oil avocado oil uh lard so as
you can see there's a lot of problem
with this unsaturated fatty acid it's
very very unstable it's not like
saturated fats that are stable that are
very difficult to break up this stuff
right here is highly susceptible to
becoming damaged and then creating
oxidation and so in the family of U
unsaturated fatty acids you have two
different main categories you have the
Omega 6 six fatty acids and then you
have the omega-3 fatty acids so this
would be mainly Omega 6 right and we
want like a one:1 ratio but the problem
is when you get into canola oil and some
of these other highly processed seed
oils that's like a
311 to1 ratio right very heavy on the
Omega 6 but in America the ratio of
Omega 6 to omega3 is roughly anywhere
between 10 to 1 to 20 to1 very heavy on
the Omega 6 and even in certain parts of
the world it can get up to like 50 to1
so you have this massive amount of
omega-6 that's kind of evading our cell
membranes creating all sorts of
inflammation Not Just In Our arteries
but also going into the retina of the
eye so if someone tells you that this
oil is not a problem for our bodies it's
fresh no it's not it's badly processed
and this introduction into our bodies is
directly correlated with heart disease
so here's the problem Omega 6 and
omega-3 are competitive which means that
you're going to have to get this Omega 6
seed oils out of the diet and replace
with omega-3 which is from the fish oils
the cod liver oil you're going to get
more of it when you have grass-fed meat
but we want to start increasing this
omega3 to counter the effects of the
Omega 6 now I don't want to get into the
history of this but wow we just did a
whole switch and we replaced saturated
fats with seed
oils thinking that was a smart move it
was not a smart move now people are
waking up it's Insidious it crept into a
lot of our different foods and no wonder
we're having so many problems I think
one of the mistakes early on was because
it lowered cholesterol we assumed it was
good for the heart and so it was
promoted widely before any human studies
were done in the beginning it's in baby
food it's in infant formula I mean they
just put in everything
now in the first video that I did on
trans fats even though it's not a main
problem in our diet they still stick it
in from various ways and they sneak it
in there uh I think it'd be very smart
to watch that video I will put that up
right here check it
out